finally tonight I don't usually give
advice but I think everyone should count
your blessings my family is tonight my
wife Amy and sons Paul and Daniel once
skiing in Montana this weekend we had a
fantastic trip there's a lot of fun
gorgeous snow a lot of quality family
time some fate safe fun skiing without
incident which is always nice I drove
the family Monday morning to the airport
in Bozeman and it was snowing and the
roads were icy and approaching an
intersection just two miles from the
airport I hit a big patch of ice and I
could not stop our SUV we slid into the
intersection of a busy road and into the
path of a big pickup truck which slammed
into our driver side door the airbags
deployed the windows shattered we
careened into a ditch and flipped
sideways and I started to try to push
open the passenger door to get us out
then a man held open the door so we
could climb out
Zach Black was driving by just stopped
to help us we climbed out the driver of
the pickup truck David had called the
police and the EMS and was concerned
about our family first and foremost
Montana Highway Patrol quickly arrived
EMS paramedics from Belgrade and Bozeman
arrived quickly - and we escaped with
minor injuries a concussion 14 stitches
on the chin a jostle tooth and a
sprained ankle we are very blessed Thank
You Zach black and for all the Zach's
across the country who stopped thank you
David
Thank You Montana Highway Patrol and EMS
personnel who were all amazing as we
were released from the hospital I
tweeted this
don't take anything for granted every
day is a blessing family's everything
it's always good to remind yourself of
that before something does it before you
count your blessings and I meant it
sorry I had to be here today to show you
I was okay